[Music]
[Music]
my name is marco and today is about
getting started with time series
forecasting in python as you may know
i'm writing a book time series
forecasting in python with manning
so this book has really four key skills
recognize the time series forecasting
problem
build univariate and multivariate
forecasting models
also leverage large data sets using deep
learning models and then we conclude the
book with automating the forecasting
process
with some of the automated forecasting
libraries that are out there i really
the main
differentiating point of this book is
that everything is in python and i also
make sure to include tons of real life
scenarios and use cases for us to
practice what we learn
as well as capstone projects with full
solutions available
so really
i think really interesting and really a
great way to apply what we learn
so
this presentation here really focuses on
the basics the fundamentals of time
series forecasting so concepts that will
come back over and over again as we
learn
more about time series forecast
and so we first answer the question what
a time series is and so simply a time
series is a set of data points ordered
in time right so it is data that was
recorded uh with equal spaces and type
so recorded every hour minute day month
quarter etc
so here is an example of a time series
right so this is the monthly
number of anti-diabetic drug
prescriptions in australia so this is an
example of data that is recorded every
month okay
here we have another example of a time
series in this case it is quarterly data
so it is the quarterly earnings per
share for the company johnson and
johnson so it is recorded every three
months in a year
and here we have another
time series example which is traffic
volume so the number of cars that are
passing through an interstate road
and so in this case uh it is recorded
every hour and so of course it makes
sense right so during the day you're
gonna have some peaks
throughout the day so maybe right before
work and right after work and then at
night traffic is really
low pretty much nobody's using the roads
anymore so those are all examples of
time series datasets and this is the
type of data that we learned to forecast
uh with time series right
and so every time series can really be
broken down into three components okay
the first component is the trend and
that represents the long term change in
the time series so this is what is
responsible for the time series to
either increase or decrease over time
and sometimes you can have no trend at
all right and so your time series is
neither increasing or decreasing
then we have the seasonal component
which is when we see a periodic pattern
in a time series so this is like the
repeated fluctuations that occur over a
fixed period of time
and then finally we have the residuals
which is noise or irregularities that
are not explained by the trend or the
seasonal component
so here's an example you know of time
series decomposition so at the very top
we have the observed data sets which is
your time series data as you would see
it so in this case it is the
number of monthly air passengers
and then we decompose the time series
into its components so
the second plot you see the trend so of
course as you can see we have a time
series that over the long term is
increasing over time and this is what
the trend component is telling us
it is also increasing over time so
that's great
then we have the seasonal component and
the seasonal component really captures
what you what we call uh the periodic
fluctuations in the time series okay so
as you can see every year is going up
and down and up and down and this is
what the seasonal component is telling
us
and finally we have the residuals which
is any variations in the time series
that are not explained by the trend and
the seasonal component so as you can see
the residuals they seem a bit random
they go up they go down sometimes
positive sometimes negative and so
when you add all those components back
so if you add the residuals with the
seasonal component and the trend
component you're gonna get back your
observed data
so this is very exciting right uh we
know what time series are we know its
components we want to forecast them
however this is not always
we cannot always forecast all time
series that we will counter and one
example of that is when we encounter a
random walk so a random walk is an
example of a time series that we cannot
reasonably forecast so let's understand
why
so here's an example of a random one
okay actually this is the closing price
of the alphabet stock price
which has the ticker google
this is this was taken from may 2020 to
end of may 2021.
so as you can see there is some kind of
trend right so it's increasing over time
sometimes it's going up sometimes it's
going down
etc so we want to know can we actually
forecast the daily closing price of
google okay
well first we need to first identify is
it a random walk or not because if it is
a random walk then we can't really
reasonably forecast it
so a random walk is defined as a process
in which there is an equal chance of
going up or down by a random number and
this type of data is usually observed in
financial and economic data
so mathematically we say that the random
walk the present value yt depends on a
constant
denoted as c
the past value of the time series
denoted as y t minus one so just the
value of the time series but one step
before
and an error term epsilon t
and so this is the mathematical
expression of a random log and already
we can see why we cannot reasonably
forecast a random block right because
basically we can say that uh the future
value right here yt
is only dependent on the present value
plus some kind of random number and of
course we cannot reasonably forecast a
random number because it is
random in the end okay
so it's very important to recognize when
we have a random walk process
and this is the kind of procedure that
we follow to identify a random walk
process so first of all we'll gather the
data of course we need data to work with
type series forecasting and then we'll
check for stationary so we'll check is
our series stationary and if it is not
the case then we need to apply a
transformation until the series is
stationary
and once that is the case we plot the
acf okay or the autocorrelation function
and then when we look at the acf we'll
determine is there autocorrelation if
there is no autocorrelation we say it is
a random walk otherwise we have
something else
so i know there is a lot of new concepts
that i've just introduced here so let's
take the time to go through each one of
them
so first of all stationarity what it is
a stationary process is defined as
having a constant statistical properties
over time therefore the mean the
variance and the autocorrelation are
constant they do not depend with time
so let's show you an example here in
orange we have an example of a
non-stationary process and in blue we
have an example of a stationary process
already we can see that the orange
process uh the non-stationary one has
some kind of trend right it first
decreases and then it decreases over
time however looking at the blue process
the stationary process there's no really
trend in here right it seems to hover
around the same value throughout time
this is just a quick way for you to
already get it get a hint that you may
be working with a random walk or not
but of course we will see how to test it
statistically
but so now let's take a look at the
statistical properties of these two
processes to see if
one of them is constant
or not
so here we take a look at the mean of
the time series over time
so again in blue as you can see for the
stationary process once you give it a
few time steps for the mean to stabilize
the mean stays fairly constant over time
it does not change anymore however for
the orange process as you can see the
mean changes drastically over time
which is really so now we can see you
know for a stationary process the mean
stays constant but for non-stationary
process the mean is really a function of
time
and the same happens with the variance
so again giving a few time steps for the
variance to stabilize and you see a blue
flat line
telling us that the variance is indeed
constant over time for the stationary
process however looking again at the
orange line for the non-stationary
process variance is again a function of
time it is changing in order to make our
series stationary we need to apply
transformations and the most common
transformation that we apply
to rendered time series stationary is
called differencing
so different thing is very simple we
actually just state the difference
between consecutive time steps okay so
as you can see here at the very top we
have our original time series starting
at y 0 all the way to the end and then
we apply a first order differencing
which is simply we're going to take the
difference between each consecutive time
step
so here we do y1 minus y0 and then y2
minus y1 y3 minus y2 so on and so forth
and then the result is a is what we call
a differenced time series and note that
for the very first time step we lose one
data point because at y0 there is no
previous time step with which to uh to
take the difference okay so every time
we difference we lose one data point
important to keep that in mind and that
is very simple to do in python so of
course this is time series forecasting
in python right
so in python very simple uh using the
library numpy so anyone who has done
data science uh has probably used numpy
uh so they it comes with the diff method
which in which we simply pass in our
data and then we specify n which is the
order of differencing so in this case n
is equal to one for a first order
differencing so that means that we're
going to be differencing between
consecutive steps
and then once we have different power
series you know we need to test for
stationarity and the way to do that we
apply a statistical test called the
augmented d key fuller test or for short
we call it the adf test
and the adf test is what we use to test
for stationarity and its null hypothesis
is
a unit root is present therefore the
series is not stationary
and so in order to reject the null
hypothesis we need to have a p-value
that is less than 0.05
in that case you know we reject the null
hypothesis and so we conclude that the
series is stationary
and again uh running the adf test is
very straightforward with python so we
use the library's stats models that
applies a bunch of
statistical models especially for time
series forecasting very
very useful so from stats models we can
simply import the add fuller function
and so as you can see so we first
difference our random walk and then we
test it using the adf
test and we simply pass in our
difference random block and then we can
print out
both the adf statistic and the p-value
the ids statistic by the way is simply a
negative number so for a
stationary process the adf statistic
will be a large negative number
however i don't recommend
only placing your conclusion on the adf
statistic because a large negative
number is somewhat subjective
so always print out the p-value and
really use that to make your your
decision in this case if the p-value is
less than 0.05 like i said you can
safely
reject the null hypothesis and conclude
that your time series is stationary
and then once uh we know that we have a
stationary process we can then plot the
acf which is which stands for
autocorrelation function
the autocorrelation function simply
measures the correlation of a time
series with itself at past values which
we also call lag values okay so past
values and lag values means the same
thing
and this is the kind of result that you
get uh so as you can see uh first at lag
zero we always have an auto correlation
coefficient of one
that makes sense right because this
simply means what is the correlation of
y zero with y y0 okay so what is the
correlation of a value with itself
that's always going to be equal to one
right because the value
with itself is always equal okay
and then we look what is the correlation
of a present value with its past value
and then with two values prior to that
and then three values prior to that and
so on and so forth so this is what the
x-axis is telling us is how many lags
we are comparing to
and so here actually is an example of an
autocorrelation function that shows no
autocorrelation okay so you might notice
this uh white this um
sorry this um pale blue rectangle here
and that shows the confidence
significance interval okay so if your
autocorrelation coefficients represented
by these dots here is within this pale
blue rectangle it means that they are
not significantly different from zero
and so you can say that the the
coefficients are not significant so
there is no autocorrelation however if
they are
outside of this pale
blue rectangle
then your then your coefficients are
significant and you must consider that
there is no correlation
so looking at this acf okay this is a
typical acf of a random walk okay or
random noise here because we we will
always have an auto correlation
coefficient of one at lag zero and then
nothing will be significant at future
lags
and again to plot the acf very simple we
use again the stats models library that
has the plot acf function
in there and again we simply pass it
our difference
process in this case it is a stationary
process and then you can specify the
number of lags which simply tells you
how far you go on the x-axis so in this
case we put lags equal 20 which is why
you see here we go from zero all the way
to 20.
and now let's check if google is a
random mark okay so we follow the same
process so we had our google data we
differenced it to make it stationary and
then we plot the acf function and this
is the acl function that we get so as
you can see of course at zero we have
our
correlation coefficient of one that's
fine but then as you move out you see
nothing is significant besides this one
here at lag five
so what happened here okay
this sometimes can happen okay um you
might have by chance a significant
coefficient okay
why do i say it is by chance it's
because there are no consecutive uh
significant coefficients okay it's
really at zero we have one and then
nothing is significant and then we just
have this little blip here at lag five
and then nothing is significant anymore
okay that's why i say it occurs by
chance and
sometimes it happens but from this year
we can really say that well the daily
closing price of google seems to be a
random walk and so
it's probably not really reasonable to
try to predict it
and actually we have to be very careful
when we forecast the random block
because we're only left
with using very naive methods okay
and here here's an example of uh me
trying to forecast the random block okay
so we have the actual values in blue and
then in red we have the forecast
now if we were to evaluate such a model
you know maybe measure its msc
its mean squared error or its mean
absolute error where we get some very
low scores trying to you know hinting us
that we actually built a very good model
but if we look closely at it the only
thing that we did is that we're simply
predicting uh the actual time step to be
the same in the future so what we're
saying here is that well whatever the
closing price it was today all i'm
saying is that it is going to be the
same the next day
and then when you think about it you're
only going to be off by a very small
random number okay
so it seems like to be a very smart
forecast a very good forecast where in
fact we're not doing anything
intelligent here
so be careful
when you're forecasting a random walk
or when you see forecasts of random
walks like this because we might think
that it's a very good but in fact
there's nothing really smart going on
here
you